these new 19 Apple earpods support
lossless audio where the airpods max for
550 do not even if you use their wired
cable connection so today we will see
just how good these earpods are we're
gonna test out if they work with Samsung
devices and we're gonna compare them to
Wireless Apple airpods not only in terms
of sound quality but also in terms of
microphones and other things to see is
one of Apple's least expensive products
worth buying in 2023. now earpods used
to come with your iPhone when you bought
them and back then we didn't really pay
them any attention I just left them in
the box of course we had the three and a
half mil versions and then the lightning
versions but now that the iPhone 15s are
switching to USB type c Apple has
updated and I've heard that they sound
even better let's go ahead and pop these
oh open it's interesting that recently
there's been a trend where people are
using wired headphones with a mic for
audio so I'm really curious how it
compares to wireless headphones I'm
excited to test that out but let's go
ahead and pull this out there is our USB
type-c connection if I can get it out of
here guys I feel some Nostalgia coming
on using wired headphones for so many
years and apple just destroyed that
market I have to say that the quality
feels really nice this cable is very
very flexible it's quite slim now it's
not braided it would be cool if they
matched the new cables that come with
the iPhones and some of the other
products but the quality for 19 bucks
feels really nice and like I mentioned
this actually has a digital to analog
converter built into it that supports
lossless audio you guys let me know
would you rather buy these ear pods or
Apple 19 polishing cloth because they
cost exactly the same now these actual
buds they seem a little bit smaller than
I remember the airpods being these are
the airpods three I haven't used them
for a while but let's go ahead and pull
this out yep definitely so if we take a
look the wired ones are quite a bit
smaller they are thinner as well just
overall a smaller shape and size now of
course the wireless ones have a bunch of
other stuff built in we have batteries
we have a bunch of Bluetooth things
chips where these ones do not need that
let's go ahead and do a little Comfort
test we have the airpods 3 which are
bigger these things are really
comfortable I do feel them but they are
great and these guys look more like the
original ear pods and um some people
said that these sound better than
airpods version number two so here
they're lighter I don't feel them as
much because there's smaller so
definitely not bad I don't feel a cable
right now let's put the other one in it
it's weird not hearing a little
connection or anything and now of course
I feel the the cable here
and our controls are right over here on
the side so you can click you can
actually fast forward you can hold down
so not bad at all now I'm gonna go ahead
and grab my MacBook here because the
iPhone 15s are not out yet let's go
ahead and plug this in bam it wants me
to allow the accessory to connect and
right here we have our ear pods bam we
are connected and it works as easy as
that and of course it should work just
fine on your iPad as well so let's plug
it in here and on this one it looks like
I don't have to give it any permissions
it just automatically connects and works
now the question is is it going to work
with other USB devices USBC like this
Samsung
bam we are connected and instantly they
show up and they are working without a
hitch but now the question is how do
they sound so I'm going to plug it into
my Mac here we're going to start out
with normal audio not lossless and let's
just take a listen moment of truth let's
hit play
I'm not maxed out yet in terms of volume
sounds pretty good good bass
vocals are kicking in
so nice and smooth so far I'm impressed
for 19 bucks
we're gonna get that beat drop really
soon here
let's go ahead and turn it up
[Music]
these Get Loud
wow this might be the best value of
2023. butim I'm off to buy more of these
yeah I'm gonna buy these for my kids
yeah this is like 19 bucks
I don't know what other headphones are
in the market that are wired at this
price point right now I have not paid
attention to that for a long time
but 19 free shipping if you actually get
them on Best Buy I think you're gonna
get three months of Apple music even for
people that tried it before and four
months of Apple TV and like Apple news
for three months or something like that
for 19 bucks and with free shipping so
if you want to get some free services
you can actually buy these to get that
man okay I'm excited to compare them to
these way more expensive but I am
impressed I think they definitely
updated some other things internally
they're probably going to be making
these for a very long time so they
wanted to do that but
um those sounded good but did you hear
any sound leakage
yeah I mean they're not sealed and they
get loud
they get loud but they sound natural you
know what I'm gonna try out these
controls right here I'm gonna hit the
center
okay automatic is controlling the Mac
we're gonna turn it up turn it back
let's press and hold
just going smooth so it looks like I
can't get a a skip on the Mac but I know
there's more things you could do man
okay once again that sounds pretty dang
good a lot better than I expected now we
are going to listen to these with
lossless as well with apple music which
you get that for free you don't have to
pay extra for lossless we're gonna
compare it to these but first I want to
compare the microphones with both of
these this is the microphone quality
using Apple's new 19 USB type-c earpods
and this is the microphone quality using
Apple's airpods 3 over Bluetooth you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below we just
listened to the recordings and I am
surprised by how good these sound now
the airpods have noise reduction built
into them whereas these do not seem to
have it and we have loud HVAC noise in
this room but connected to your iPhone
well you do have software to be able to
do noise reduction voice isolation all
sorts of stuff like that now the sound
just sounds more full and of course when
you have these in your microphone is
right here next to your mouth not all
the way up on the stem which definitely
helps them out and now I want to go
ahead and compare the sound quality
between both of these
[Music]
where we started
all right guys
I feel like I shouldn't say this but I
feel like I want to say this feels like
this is impossible
but I think these sound better
than these airpods
they sound incredibly similar
these are louder and I'm playing off of
YouTube I'm playing off of YouTube I'm
not playing an apple music we'll listen
to Apple music with losses they're
obviously louder than these and these
sound loud already the bass sounds just
as good very similar the tuning is very
similar the vocals sound a little bit
more natural
and I'm playing them louder I would not
say they sound any worse in any way
and they could sound better like if you
buy these and you have both let me know
I I just
um I was not expecting this and I don't
know if this is Placebo but it literally
seems like it could be the identical
drivers maybe different tuning maybe
with the cable right we're not using
Bluetooth we're not limited by battery
power
um I am even more impressed now with
these things and now let's go ahead and
test out the lossless audio I have a
track here that we can't play for
copyright you guys can go listen to it
it's very well recorded uh beautiful
classical song as you guys see clock
lossless shows up right here but I'm
gonna go into the settings I'm going to
disable lossless first I'll go ahead and
do some listening to both and I'll get
back to you alright guys I am once again
impressed now I wanted to make sure it
wasn't just any bias or Placebo I went
back and forth multiple times and at the
end there but even just sitting there
waiting and I'm just enjoying listening
to music so with the Lost list yes you
can tell a difference I thought with
these little earbuds you wouldn't be
able to but it's mainly in the high end
you have more detail and it is smoother
I don't know the best way to describe it
smoother and almost like there's more
depth to it now this track if you listen
to it there's a saxophone getting from
quiet to loud acquire
um it sounds really cool and you
definitely can tell the difference and
the nice thing is it doesn't cost you
anything extra you're not buying an
external DAC of course there's other
wired headphones way more expensive
they're going to sound better but these
things have just thoroughly impressed me
and if you have a source that's high
quality it will accept it and play it
instead of having to mix it down and
lowering the quality just because you
your headphones can't accept it so I
think I'm gonna buy another pair of
these These are going to be great for
kids great for keeping your bag great
for times where you just want to plug in
and listen not deal with batteries or
latency if you're gaming the yeah for 19
bucks this is a steal and if you end up
picking a pair of these up let us know
in the comments what you think of them
so thank you Apple uh this has been
probably the biggest surprise of this
September 2023 launch and I'm glad that
apple is putting USBC into the iPhone
thank you guys for watching click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great ones right over there
this has been Max and I'll see you in
the next one
foreign